well I said he had sir mark kleiman is
here with some breaking news about
another fine related to the libel rape
fixing scandal mark hello to you what
more can you tell us was there a big
city broking firm called i cap which is
well known for being run by michael
michael spencer who was the treasurer of
the Conservative Party until a couple of
years ago has just been fined fifty five
million pounds by regulators in London
and New York for its role in this global
rate-rigging conspiracy now I cap has
become the fourth firm to be fined over
this scandal the other three being
Barclays Royal Bank of Scotland and the
swiss bank ubs and this is by far the
smallest of the fines which takes
account of the fact that the regulators
have decided that the senior management
of icap was not aware of the
transgressions of its employees however
some former icap brokers are also facing
felony charges by the US Department of
Justice